derrière moi ce sont les gorges du
verdon avant elle ressemblait à ça
et maintenant ça ressemble à ça
me voilà dans les gorges des bars
pour ceux qui connaissent
pas ils vont avoir un choc donc voilà il
ya deux gars il ya 20 cm d'eau
voyez pado
le marché dans les gorges du verdon
c'est officiel
jusqu'à au dessus des rochers
voix derrière moi la limite de la boue
là il ya à peu près 50 cm même pas
l'appât du attouchements à ce niveau là
les alpes-de-haute-provence connaissent
une sécheresse historique les gorges du
verdon ont perdu parfois jusqu'à six
mètres de profondeur au pont du galetas
les kayaks et les pédalos ne peuvent pas
aller très loin car le niveau de l'eau
est trop bas
on a connu des gorges du verdon avec
l'eau pour faire l'aller comment les
dégueulasse ça sent la vase la bombe
peu dégoûté quoi
cette année il a très peu plu très peu
neigé et les nappes phréatiques n'ont
pas pu se régénérer on est sur la
situation historique on n'avait pas
connu ça ici depuis 1964 donc on n'a pas
de mémoire d'homme ça fait 60 ans qu'on
n'a pas connu ça on a 40% de deux chutes
de pluie en moins aujourd'hui
les canicules n'arrange rien l'eau
s'évapore les cours de sont au plus bas
comme ici derrière moi dans la rivière
moi je suis un peu dégoûté cet été parce
qu'on était censé aller au dune du pilat
on a été à bordeaux il ya deux semaines
et on n'a pas pu y aller parce que bah
ça a brûlé au tour et puis là ici cette
année elle j'avais vraiment envie de
venir ici et c'est pas à ce à quoi on
s'attend quoi les gens c'est
je pense le problème c'est que rien que
j'entendais encore tout à l'heure à la
radio qui demandait en corse notamment
de faire attention qu'ils ont limité à
200 litres d'eau par personne et c'est
par jour mais quand on voit derrière des
gens qui voyage en jet privé qui font
n'importe quoi qui conduisent des
voitures qui consomment à la pas
possible et qu'on leur dit rien on les
taxe pas et que c'est aux gens de la
classe moyenne où les gens pourront
enfin simple entre guillemets à faire
des efforts au quotidien au quotidien
enfin c'est pas juste en fait
ici on vient dans les gorges du verdon
notamment pour faire du rafting cette
année cette activité est impossible edf
a préféré fermer les barrages pour
garder le peu d'eau qui reste pour les
besoins humains l'irrigation agricole et
l'industrie si vous trouvez que le
niveau est bas pourtant il a été
maintenu grâce au fait qui a eu 60 % de
production électrique de moins pour
permettre au contraire de conserver un
flux d'eau qui permette de préserver les
fonctions vitales c'est le décret du 29
juillet il ya quelques jours qui va
instaurer la surveillance pendant
l'automne et l'hiver du niveau des eaux
pour que potentiellement on puisse un
jour être amené à prendre des mesures de
restriction beaucoup plus tôt dans
l'année si on pense que la pente sur
laquelle on est va nous entraîner vers
un été dans lequel les choses seront
problématiques on voit bien que
si on ne diminue pas nos habitudes de
consommation on aura des épisodes à
répétition dans lequel la question sera
plus une question de partage qui se fera
de manière consensuelle mais se fera
avec des tensions et avec des risques
pour un certain nombre de professions et
domaine ce que s'il ya bien un bien qui
nous appartient à tous ces lots